ministers attending the general affairs
council in brussels on july 23
the first under italian presidency will
discuss the work plan prepared by the
new eu presidency for the next six
months
following the meeting of the european
council on july 16 ministers will also
explore new ways to better monitor the
implementation of decisions taken by eu
leaders
during their meetings in brussels as it
works now
ministers prepare implementation reports
which are then presented to the eu
leaders
but the idea is to make the follow-up
process more effective and less
bureaucratic
ministers will also have a look at the
work that needs to be done until the end
of the year
to prepare the review of the europe 2020
growth strategy
this sets ambitious objectives on
employment innovation
education social inclusion and climate
and energy to be reached by 2020
and as next year's mid-term review of
the strategy approaches
there's a unanimous call to step up
efforts to reach the agreed targets
following the recommendation last month
of the euro area member states
the council is also expected to take the
necessary decisions
to enable lithuania's entry into the
euro club as from the 1st of january
2015.
with lithuania replacing litas for euros
the euro area will soon count
19 member states
you